the San Francisco District Attorney's
Office is going to either totally wipe
out or look at reducing several thousand
criminal convictions that are related to
marijuana some of which date back many
many decades because in 2016 California
had a ballot measure to legalize
recreational cannabis in the state and
one of the things that the law allows
for is the review and reduction or even
removal of prior convictions for
activity that would potentially be legal
under the new law and there's about
3,000 of these cases that are simply
going to be dismissed those were prior
misdemeanors and then there's about five
thousand five that five thousand felony
cases that are going to be reviewed so
to be clear this is not so much about
freeing people that are in jail or
prison a lot of these people never did
any prison or jail time although some of
them may have it's about getting rid of
their record because it has a major
impact for jobs right we've talked about
the movements that exist in some states
to ban the question about former
convictions sometimes it's misdemeanors
sometimes it's felony only but there's
different ways in which those questions
can be asked by potential employers to
applicants and there are states who have
quote banned the box as it's called and
this is going to be a major major thing
for a lot of people seeking employment
who have these misdemeanors or felonies
on their record and it's it's something
that we've seen this happen before
actually where you have something that
was previously illegal legalized but
there is no accommodation or
consideration given to those who are who
have a record for something that is no
longer illegal and there's sort of
different approaches depending on what
the acts are what how the law sees those
actions but when it comes to these
marijuana cases I am 110 percent
completely on board with this and
increasingly what we're seeing is a
growing divergence between the states
and the federal government on the issue
of cannabis right you saw during the
Obama administration numerous successful
legalization initiatives recreational
legalization decriminalization
initiatives legalization of medical
cannabis and by and large the Trump the
Obama administration rather was more
friendly than prior administrations even
though marijuana remained illegal
federally the Obama administration had
directed federal law enforcement
agencies to sort of stay out take a
hands-off approach to states that had
legalized two different degrees
cannabis either medical or recreational
or simply decriminalized that split when
Donald Trump was elected president of
the United States and selected the very
very anti pot Attorney General Jeff
Sessions who as I've told you previously
said he used to kind of like the KKK
until he found out that they smoked pot
and that was what put him over the edge
into being anti KKK and the federal
government is moving much more harshly
against marijuana Attorney General Jeff
Sessions wants to not wipe out marijuana
convictions right California wants to
wipe out marijuana convictions this is
sort of a good analogy and Jeff Sessions
wants to wipe out people using marijuana
and this has major job implications it
has for the fiscal conservatives major
fiscal implications because even though
marijuana and property seizures related
to marijuana do bring in a lot of money
the apparatus and the cost and increased
size of government and that includes DEA
ATF Border Patrol
seizing marijuana near the border a very
very long list of how this apparatus is
huge it's a ton of government spending
it is a huge amount of government
spending and hiring unemployment
all of which so-called fiscal
conservatives claim to claim to be
against and it's important to understand
the underpinnings of this it's important
to understand how in some
some areas some enclaves of the
electorate in the same way that you can
raise a lot of money being anti-gay or
being anti-abortion you can raise money
being anti pot it's disgusting and I am
thrilled that San Francisco's District
Attorney is going to take the California
law as an opportunity to do this and I
hope that other California District
Attorney's will do the exact same thing